so one of the things you mentioned when
we were out is
a music video yeah
okay so i'm very excited about it why is
that happening what when is it coming
out okay in the next two weeks i'm not
sure when this is coming out but it's
coming out soon and
yeah i'm doing music it should be out if
it's out it will be linked okay sweet
link it up thanks
for doing music i am doing music and you
saw it and you you kind of i'm not sure
if did you hear it could you hear where
we were i couldn't hear it super clearly
but i saw it you saw it okay what was
your initial reaction
it's like a legit music video it looks
very cool yay thanks uh i directed and
i'm doing music and so many people was
that in nashville
that one yeah i recorded that in
nashville but i started doing music like
four years ago and then the thing that
you hear from a lot of people happened
where producers started fighting with
managers over who owns this and who
whatever and i just went
nope uh there's enough drama i'm not
doing this [ __ ] i've seen it happen to
artists so i just dropped the project
and just kept going on with my other
stuff
and then
yeah i missed those songs i might be
getting them back though
yikes yeah but it wasn't worth the fight
to me i'm like no i don't want this
negative energy on a project i'm about
to release so forget about it and then
i just did this one track in nashville
and i've since done a bunch of tracks
and the first one's coming out with the
video ryan long who we both know who has
been a friend of mine for like 15 years
now he's like the sibling i never wanted
uh
that's how i think of ryan i'm just like
ah you're like my brother that i didn't
want uh
always tells the truth uh he's like
don't do music it'll end your career but
he hasn't seen or heard it so
everyone who's actually seen or heard it
is like
[ __ ]
it'll end your joke i don't think that's
necessarily true i think like even if
first of all i don't think it's gonna go
badly but i can see why he would say
like don't do it in case it goes you end
up with like a flop and then you're
forever known as the bad music video
person yeah yeah but doesn't that also
sometimes make people's
careers or does it just destroy their
lives i appreciate it
yeah like well i'm not that that's the
thing is like i would like that though
that's kind of sad
are you sure you don't want to do no no
i'm good that's not what your music
video looks like no
or the song i know people are going to
be surprised and i've so here's the
thing here's how i knew that it like
it doesn't suck is it was sent to some
people including world star and they
were like whoa oh okay i was like if
anybody's going to roast me on this [ __ ]
yeah you send it to those it will be
world i sent it to all the people that i
know would roast me
like the hardest and all of them went
holy [ __ ]
dope and i was like hey
[ __ ] are you coming yeah it's
just it's fun it's different part of my
personality that i've kept hidden
because i'm scared of being famous
yeah it's true
scared of being famous yeah okay let's
get into that why here we go yeah i want
to talk about the like i'm going to be
super comfy let's do this i wish tell me
if i messed up your mic okay my legs are
going to go crazy if i do something like
that i'm just going to stay ignorant
exactly
okay this works and i'll just like turn
and look at you dope um
fame fame
[ __ ] weird it's weird it's a weird
thing that i've had
i won't say a small taste of because for
most people it's
definitely more than they will ever
experience in their lifetime
and
it's weird and it scares me and people
start
treating you differently and like let's
say britney spears like i saw what
happened to britney situation
it's completely [ __ ] it's [ __ ] and
it's [ __ ] because it's the people
around her that she should have been
able to trust that did it to her i bet
it was you know what i think it is go on
i think it's psych meds i think she had
anxiety and they put her on psych meds
and the psych meds made everything
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes a hundred percent but
they put her on those psych meds to make
her go crazy so they can get videos of
her going crazy so they can capture her
money oh no that's like i was that bad
oh yeah i've watched the documentaries i
haven't so two years ago i think there
was an article put out and i had
commented that britney was put on drugs
this is a person on psych drugs oh yeah
and everyone was like shut up you don't
know what you're talking about that's in
the documentary that's exactly what
happened you were right i was right
those are something yeah you can see
that yeah
and but she's around people that she's
supposed to trust and they did that to
her and when there's money involved when
there's whatever like
just with the stuff i've been through
with people just making up [ __ ] about me
that's nasty and disgusting and just
like whatever and just so the opposite
of who i am as a human
it's not fun
it's not fun i like i love the art i
love being funny i love making people
happy and cheering for people
that other part sucks it's not cool and
i couldn't imagine being like justin
bieber and being like a teen and going
through that and that's like i kind of
feel like i've pussied out a little bit
in my career and not gone like full out
yet because i was a little nervous about
that part
but
yeah well yeah we talked a little bit
about this um when we went out yeah and
it was that if something happens
then not only do you have to deal with
the problem in your personal life and
freak out about it like on a personal
level
but you have to go okay how is this
going to be interpreted yeah how do i
get ahead of that yep and so then you
have to put out a story for people
getting ahead of it is get ahead of it
before you're ready to talk about it
because you're still right in the middle
of some crisis yep it's horrible it's
not fun but you know people would be
like oh wow
oh so hard being famous yeah yeah and
you're like okay
everybody has issues because you could i
get it you could also
i mean the argument is well if you don't
want that then just stop do something
else yeah but then there are but then my
spirit will die yeah yeah then i won't
be alive as a person
um
yeah those are some thoughts on fame and
we've discussed this before like i've
had people make up really weird [ __ ]
about me and then
it affects you in a strange way because
when it's not true
even if millions of people
think something about you that's not
true and is nasty
it affects you on the daily because
those people are looking at you thinking
that's who you are as a person and the
strongest person you'd be like it
doesn't affect me it doesn't [ __ ]
matter but it does
and it's weird having other people
tell the world who i am
so all i can really do is what i've
decided is just like keep being me
and it will come out
like i just know
people will see who i am and people will
see who the people are that have like
spread nasty [ __ ] i feel like that is a
more positive way of looking at it than
i think ah because that like that's what
i would hope yeah is just like ignore
and that's what a lot of people say is
like ignore the haters just keep being
you spread and and people will just know
yeah but people are stupid there's lots
of really stupid people well hence the
comment sections on youtube people only
hear one thing yeah i think like if that
kind of
disaster happens you have to get out
there and say okay
here's my explanation i didn't really
want to do this but here's the story you
guys can make up your own minds but at
least now you have the information yeah
it's a weird thing
it's so weird and like
this is what we talked about the other
night is like i love hanging out with
you because we have the same kind of
problems and it makes me feel more
normal we can both like just kind of
[ __ ] our problems out and we don't look
at each other like an alien [ __ ] i
kind of looked at you a little bit like
an alien why would you do that well
you're you were so i was so grumpy so it
was really nice to go out with you but
you're so like bubbly in a i was just
like is that you like really and you're
like yeah
wow that's so cool
you said that like five times wow like
you're like you're really like this i'm
like yeah
it's like like i said like there's like
my serious tone like i was just doing
this is serious tone yeah there's my
like
bubbly that's me all the time
i wake up like that
[Music]
you